the number one question i get is how to
play up your eyes
i'm gonna show you the smokey eye a
smokey eye is layered
do not get a dark black shadow
and put it all over your eye my makeup
philosophy
is that i like it to be quick i like it
to be natural
it's not about how you look it's about
what you do look like
makeup is a way to change the way you
feel
make you comfortable in your skin and
enhance who you are
i love when she smiles you see the
little lines and you know what
we have lines and that's okay you have
to embrace
yourself embrace your age no matter what
color skin you have
what color eyes you have what color hair
you have anyone could make themselves
look beautiful
[Music]
i'm going to teach you how to cover up
the little pesky spots on your face
how to use anything from a pencil to a
cream to even coconut oil
this is like an ideal treatment bronzer
101 use a wide brush
dip the brush in tap it glow to get it
off and that way
you don't make a mess on the skin all
right let's do your eyes first
make sure you're blending it fingers are
the best way to blend
oh i love this i would like to demystify
your makeup kit
you need a moisturizer black mascara
four
shadows a brush a pencil and that's
pretty much it
makeup should not be a mask makeup
should not change the way you look
you don't wear foundation to change the
color of your skin you
don't contour your nose there's nothing
wrong with your nose
you don't over line your lips makeup
should enhance
who you are she doesn't need anything
else she looks
absolutely gorgeous you're gonna call me
every day right yeah
every day i'm bobby brown and this
is my master class
[Music]
you